freunde herzlich willkommen zu diesem
video ist wirklich ein krasses videos
hat mir ein paar kopfschmerzen bereitet
aber wir haben das schlechteste
restaurant in meiner stadt getestet das
schlechteste restaurant in köln und es
war ereignisreich so viel kann man
glaube ich sagen aber bevor es losgeht
zeige ich euch erstmal wovon wir
überhaupt sprechen ich bin nämlich auf
tripadvisor gegangen und habe das
schlechteste restaurant ausgesucht hier
steht zwar platz 1883 von 1885 aber die
beiden restaurants darunter haben super
wenige oder fast keine bewertung deshalb
habe ich nicht so rein gezählt hier
reden wir aber von zwei von fünf sternen
aus 269 bewertungen und für diese
bewertung kann man sich schon fast
vorstellen muss einiges schief gehen wir
gucken aber erstmal in die bewertung und
ich sage so viel ich bin komplett
neutral an die sache rangegangen und
genauso lesen jetzt auch die bewertung
also 2,0 sterne wenig ausgezeichnet sehr
viel ungenügend dann noch ein bisschen
im mittelfeld der neueste kommentar
eigentlich keinen stern wert tolle lage
am rhein das war es aber auch absolut
unfreundlich und das essen ein witz fünf
sterne bewertung wir haben dort sehr
leckere waffeln und einen sehr guten
cappuccino getrunken ein stern an
unfreundlichkeit nicht zu übertreffen
mit abstand die unfreundliche bedienung
die wir je erlebt haben schlechter
geht's kaum
unfassbar personal hat kopfhörer deshalb
leute so ein unterschiedliches bild was
sich da zeichnet in den bewertungen ich
habe es als meine pflicht gesehen für
euch und für mich selbst zu checken ist
das wirklich so schlecht ist es wirklich
das schlechteste restaurant in köln wir
sind hingefahren und hier seht ihr
unseren test hinter uns ist jetzt das
restaurant und wir laufen jetzt gleich
mal so vorbei als werden wir einfach nur
ein paar touristen mit ihrer schönen
lesbar vorbeigefahren sind und dann
werden die uns vielleicht anquatschen
mal dass so eine straße stehen leute vor
den restaurants und probieren aktiv die
leute und ich glaube wir müssen auf
jeden fall bei unserem auftritt schon
mal vorsichtig sein dass die nicht
direkt in der kamera aber die sollen
denken touristen haben glück gehabt dass
wir im freien raum
und dann testen wir alles das sieht
schon ausgerissen
wir wissen nämlich was was ist
ja wir würden eine kleinigkeit essen ja
was findest du schöner schatten ist gut
da eine sehr coole
schon mal eine flasche wasser oder
darstelle ist wasser gerne also
begrüßung sehr freundlich erstmal würde
ich sagen das sieht jetzt nicht schön
aus hier kann man jetzt nicht anders
sagen dagegen eine karte auf englisch
viele wahrscheinlich halt wie gesagt der
touristische wurden angesprochen
das passende auto ist ein bisschen laut
bima faire frühstück also zieht schön
und so ging erstmal schön flott macht
also die front da drüben ist halt schon
design technik gibt es raum auf jeden
fall ne lage im grünen direkt am rhein
man sieht auf jeden fall auf den
nachbarn auch so viele probiert leser
kunden so richtige was also sehr typisch
deutsch ist sondern ganz die frage was
ist sowas würden leute hier bestellen
spargel wurde empfohlen diversen spargel
gestellt und dann so was klassisch ist
so sauerkraut was die leute bestellen
durch kepler ist eigentlich gut
dann stellen wir schon mal die vorspeise
am besten sind wir vielleicht wollen wir
aufmerksam auch schon mit einer abfolge
könnt ihr hier schon mal großvater
bekommen als vorspeise die klasse
klassischer einfach gucken ohne sieg ein
geschichte der sympathische kasseler auf
sauerkraut mit kartoffelpüree und salat
so danke schön wir wissen auch was wir
als haupt nämlich einmal die 810 bitte
genau kaster bin ich sehr gespannt auf
die portionsgröße von 27 eur 16
muss sehr gut sein und muss groß sein
bei dem preis ist so ein ding also wer
jetzt das mittagessen bekommen
die vorspeise werden das hat nicht
überzeugt also das ist relativ haber
nicht knusprig irgendwie riecht nach
nichts die tomaten
wir haben keine süße reihenweise aniko
trennte man sich keinerlei braune farbe
fällt mit essig essenz auf günstig man
hat auch das gefühl das sind so die
günstigen discounter tomatensalat oben
sehr trocken
das sieht besser aus als es schmeckt
auch so hier mit diesem gestreuten auf
um es ist schon dann kann ich sagen dass
es mit los ist aber es ist extrem
kostenoptimiert von denen von der
qualität der der bestandteile und das
schmeckt man das merkt man also ist auch
nicht mutig geburten droht hier war sehr
thuine der angeklagte sehr sauer er
bisher muss man wirklich sagen also gehe
ich mit der bewertung wenn wir mal über
die location sprechen top lage direkt am
rhein kein schöner laden keinen schönen
laden von freundlicher service schneller
service wir warten jetzt schon ein
bisschen auf unseren hauptgang quasi
aber noch voll im rahmen haben noch die
vorspeise aber ja sehr funktional
massenstart uhr bis am rhein bis 4 grad
am dom gewesen um die ecke und lässt
schnell was essen ist eine englische
karte weil irgendwie officer
angesprochen wird frei gezogen aber
natürlich was wir jetzt mal was jetzt
nur sagen müssen wo man sich auch ein
bisschen distanzieren muss für den 3 ist
die größte frechheit es schon also ich
hab halt wo man also ich hab nichts mehr
gegessen und hätte schon lust auch etwas
gutes
hätte ich mit rechnen können gefunkt hat
man das irgendwie so hält ist das ding
ist wenn ich jetzt nicht mit dem wissen
dass es auch schlechte freundin würde
sondern zufällig hier sitzen wird und
das war auf dem teller hat er richtig
sauer für den preis fallen ich würde
mich abgezockt
thurid rapper bei mir bitte danke schön
danke sehr doch schön haus teil darauf
freue ich mich jetzt also drei stangen
spargel drei kartoffeln vier halbe
scheiben schinken 15 euro und über alles
und ida odinga klingt probieren denn man
will ja gar nicht sportlich wie lang
geht ja schon so dass betroffene mein
gott kam nicht mal rein unter gabe
stoffe gerechter kampf haben sie eine
gemüsebrühe sind eingerührt das will ich
das rennen sind
nein das hat nichts damit zu tun dass
wir die rezensionen kennen kommen hier
nicht rein mit einer gabel steckst du
das kabel verbirgt sich also
kartoffelbrei potter kann über einen
sparkurs fahren
der st
ich höre jetzt habe ich erlebt dass
sportlich drunter zu stunden 15 euro für
fünf euro für 18 euro beiden wahlgänge
kommentare die lage inzwischen gekauft
werden hey komm ich tot aber ich habe
das wirklich noch nicht erlebt wir
wollten eher in die andere richtung denn
schon so eine experience machen wünschen
natürlich sagen wollen es besser als man
denkt das wasser selbst müssen wir den
eigentlich sagen also hollande hat frage
weißt du was du schmeckst du friseure
vom spargelhof euro vom schlage das ist
wirklich die härter alter du kommst
nicht durch mit deinem beschränkt also
also leute wir haben es jetzt ein
relativ breites bild gemacht um die
location gut analysiert haben was zu
essen bestellt war wirklich ich glaube
eher eine sind bonus stern das ist nicht
anders ist der service kann ich nicht
anders erklären aber wir gehen jetzt ins
detaillierte review und rechnet man die
fraktion ab wir haben ein bisschen
schiss erwischt werden aber hier sehen
uns dann gleich ich hab's hat direkt mal
gesagt dass das kasseler wirklich sehr
trocken war und das ist nicht besonders
schön war wurde gar nicht weiter
beachtet
also es war eigentlich mehr so einfach
ist wissen wir ja schlechter ist als
hätte man hat schon häufiger gehört
detaillierte kritik werde ich auch noch
veröffentlichen auf jeden fall so
schreibt dann müssen was zusammen keine
kritik und er hat das recht hier mal am
tag fahren die leute
das ist kein restaurant wo leute ist
zwei mal essen
das geht wirklich nur darum heime laut
ramsauer es gibt hier keinen stammtisch
denn es gibt hier keine stark und ich
habe jetzt auf jeden fall ein sehr gutes
bild und kann gleich mal mehr zu
erzählen also das war unsere erfahrung
man muss wirklich sagen entgegen der
ganzen kommentare war der service bei
uns wirklich super einwandfrei ganz ganz
wichtig ist aber auf gar keinen fall
hingehen und was gegen das restaurant
sagen der bewertung schreiben ohne ta
gewesen zu sein oder in irgend einer
form die leute kontaktieren der kellner
war super und das essen war einfach
nicht lecker insbesondere in bezug auf
das preis-leistungs-verhältnis daher ist
auch das video gemacht und den namen
genannt bei mir einfach wichtig ist dass
niemand in diese situation gerät in die
wir uns absichtlich begeben haben aber
genug der erklärenden worte hier kommt
meine bewertungen
nachdem ich auf grund der schlechten
bewertung neugierig geworden war wollte
ich mir ein eigenes bild vom restaurant
dem service und dem essen machen als wir
in die nähe des restaurants kam wurden
wir auch schon freundlich aber bestimmt
von einem kellner angesprochen ob wir
einen drink zu uns nehmen möchten
der hörer auch im folgenden für unseren
tisch zuständig und zeigte sich
professionell und aufmerksam
kurz nachdem wir uns gesetzt haben
brachte er uns die karte aufgrund derer
sich das restaurant preislich in der
oberen mittelklasse einordnen lässt
wir bestellten eine flasche stilles
wasser sieben euro 20 für 0,75 liter und
brust kette ebenfalls 27 als hauptspeise
entschieden wir uns für kastler mit
kartoffelpüree und sauerkraut 14 80
sowie spargel mit salzkartoffeln und
schinken von der tageskarte 15 80 neben
der bestellten brusca erhielten wir als
beilage zum hauptgericht auch
pizzabrötchen mit dip und einen kleinen
beilagensalat bereits hier offenbarte
sich jedoch der wohl größte kritikpunkt
kostenoptimierung ohne rücksicht auf
verluste keine der vorspeisen wirkte als
wäre sie frisch zubereitet worden
die gebastelten möhren auf dem salat
waren angetrocknet und stellenweise
ergraut und der cvag tipp zudem
pizzabrötchen leicht säuerlich bei der
buchkette hatten wir aufgrund des
preises höhere erwartungen doch wurden
enttäuscht auf fünf kleinen scheiben
baguette welches nicht an größte zu sein
schienen wurden wässrige tomaten
platziert gewürze wurden nur zaghaft
eingesetzt so offenbarte der erste biss
ein trockenes und fades
geschmackserlebnis auch im hauptgang
wurden unsere geschmacklichen
erwartungen und betroffen
während sich auch bei den vorherigen
tellern durchaus mühe bei der
einrichtung gegeben wurde lag auch bei
den letzten gerichten offensichtlich der
fokus auf kostenoptimierung die drei
stangen spargel waren fahrt und leicht
säuerlich und wurden mit eineinhalb
salzkartoffeln und zwei scheiben
schinken serviert der schinken war
leicht angetrocknet
auch das kasseler war trocken und an
einer stelle leicht verband
kartoffelpüree und sauerkraut waren in
ordnung
die kritik am essen vor ort wurde nicht
weiter beachtet aufgrund der lage und
der professionellen bedienung vergebe
ich zwei von fünf punkten das war es
auch ein video leute es war auf jeden
fall ein aufregendes projekt ich habe
auf jeden fall auch bock das mit dem
teuersten restaurants machen mit dem
besten restaurant habt ihr darauf lust
schreibe es in die kommentare und bleibt
anständig wir sehen uns besser etwas
geschafft
[Musik]